hello you're playing the waiting game
the show about games that aren't out yet
unless you're watching this years from
now on your xbox to tell me can you game
and skype at the same time yet it you
can't a to processor-intensive yeah
that's too bad until that glorious skype
free future arrives we're twiddling our
thumbs waiting to play some dying light
it's an action zombie FPS survival title
for xbox one and 360 Playstation 3 and 4
and PC and with any luck it will be
coming out in 2014 well you've been
trapped in this concrete rat cage for
two months now though still alive live
in the barricaded safe zones during the
day some venture out to scavenge and
Luke whatever supplies they can find but
at night we are the hunted ones by day
you'll be scavenging the world for
supplies setting traps and hurling
yourself around the world with
fancy-pants parkour by nightly otherwise
dos I'll zombies change their tune to
become crazed flesh-hungry bastards the
other thing is it's sort of being made
by Techland the guys that made dead
island riptide remember how the explodey
boat trailer was all great and then how
the game made you want to drive nails
into your own skull rather than the
zombies well fingers crossed they're not
lying when they say that tying light
won't be a giant pile of horse crap they
never strictly said but they didn't ever
not say it either let's kick things off
with some fine horror literature in the
form of i am legend by richard matheson
it's the novel that inspired the 2007
feature film of the same name though
this book has actually been adapted into
no less than five films it even laid the
foundation for the 1968 horror flick
Night of the Living Dead No
of the Living Dead the Dead live on
living flesh interestingly this 1954
tale actually paints the rising dead as
a vampiric faux rather than zombies
Robert Neville's barricaded himself
inside his Los Angeles home as he
battles to find a cure for something he
appears to be immune to as with dying
light the monsters in i am legend are
almost harmless during the daylight
hours allowing level to venture out into
the world clear out some of the infected
with a swift stake through the hearts I
collect everything he needs to live do
his research and stave off going
completely insane through crippling
loneliness just right for finding your
own quiet space the book paints a
different and vastly more bleak ending
than the film does with jim west
desperado Roughrider know you don't want
none of them spoilers so just go and
read the book already oh the key to
effective zombie survival is cardio as
we're told in zombieland but that's not
recommendation number two no sir
although Emma Stone Mirror's Edge now
first things first no zombies not even
one but it does pit you against
basically the entire world who are
invariably more dangerous than you are
requiring you to run for your life for
the whole game dying light is about
being clever with your use of terrain
choosing smooth paths to help you race
the sunset but making them complex
enough that zombies can't catch up with
you in mirrors edge as an information
courier in a crazy dystopian future
faith also needs to use her surroundings
and routes through them wisely of course
you can steal a weapon every now and
then but ammo is a rare commodity and my
god she's a lousy shot and once you get
into the button groove you'll start
seeing every red pipe and platform as a
shining opportunity to hell yourself
into nothingness because the only other
option is real parkour and I've heard
the learning curve on that is a [ __ ]
and a 102 annayya forget this great this
[ __ ] dangerous what really is the
appeal of a zombie apocalypse is it the
lawless world the free run of the city
or is it being able to sense ously kill
mindless humans in a Rambo esque fashion
so many of these on
these stories jump straight to the
action without touching too much on the
social political or environmental
repercussions of a global pandemic World
War Z by max brooks takes a different
kind of look at the world after the dust
has settled more of a diary entry than a
single story a United Nations agent
recounts survivors tales from the eyes
of the military and civilians from all
over the world and if I know my video
editor Greg at all then chances are
you've been looking at footage from the
world war z film which frankly isn't all
that bad I mean some of the CG is pretty
lousy but through dropping the UN agent
into a series of these individual tales
you get a much broader picture of how
quickly a global crisis can spread and
how devastating it would be to the
entire world now if only there was a
playable version of that focusing on
resource gathering and stealth rather
than just all of the all-out action and
there is its state of decay more than
horror action you'll be looking at
simply surviving stata decay puts you in
the shoes of Marcus Campbell a store
clerk returning from a fishing trip to
zombie chaos you'll be required to
amount supermarket raids grow food in
your fort and engage in a mo trading
with other players a major focus of the
game is to find npcs out in the 16
square kilometer world go friend them
and use their expendable body husks to
find new base locations new raids and
other trade opportunities befriend them
enough for may become playable which is
convenient because if your character
dies or becomes zombified then they're
gone for good you can pick up a copy for
Xbox 360 or pc right now
in the likely event of a real zombie
horde taking over city it would be a
great idea to find out which of your
friends runs fastest then not be friends
with them anymore in a world of rabid
people jumpers it sucks to be at the
back of the pack what you were looking
at there was the walking dead escape
these day and nighttime sessions can be
found all over the world by varying
names some of them even include
paintball guns for that extra nugget of
violence running a large group of you
through a closed location zombified
civilians make for a tricky obstacle
course as you sprint to your way to
safety this here is how the game spot us
team did during the comic-con escaped
last year yeah of course when Greg and I
tried it it just went nothing like I
expected I think sorry well let's absorb
it to repopulate the earth 17min yeah
but what about love I mean yeah hot sexy
Phil zombies well if that doesn't keep
you busy for months and months then crap
I'm out of ideas but you smart lock arts
throw in your suggestions and help these
good folks out with your favorite zombie
media like last week when we got some
excellent suggestions for alien
isolation Charlie olek said should have
recommended natural selection 2 good
suggestion Charlie hex ID says said I
love you but you're a massive bellend
while Marcus makes an excellent
suggestion saying so far my favorite
alien game is left 4 dead 2 with mods
that change all zombies into Xenomorphs
AKA hordes of rushing aliens it's great
you know what just play left 4 dead 2
for all the games we've ever covered
chances are there's a mod out there that
makes it relevant and if you still think
I'm a massive bellend you should go and
watch GTA Diaries next where I get to be
the biggest Bell end of all you'll love
it give me give me this is one sweet
sugar catia articulate side Bernie cap
well Greg how will we get back on that a
repopulation thing yet
topology did you said zombie babies oh
my